the mother says TSA agents at
dallas-fort Worth International Airport
went too far entreated her family she
says like dogs
Jennifer Williamson posted video to
Facebook showing an agent patting down
her son she says that they were held at
the checkpoint for about an hour causing
them to miss their flight Omar
Villafranca is at the DFW Airport with
an interview that you'll see only on CBS
this morning and the TSA s response
Omar good morning good morning the TSA
says the procedure performed by that
agent on video was part of the new
standard pat-down that went into effect
earlier this month instead of several
variations there's now just one full
body pat-down well that touched a nerve
with the mother who went through
security here at DFW on Sunday with her
son we were treated with utter
disrespect as if we were criminals
Jennifer Williamson turned her anger
into action Sunday recording a TSA
officer patting down her 13-year old son
at dallas-fort Worth International
Airport and posting it on Facebook I
believe he was patted down excessively
they went over his sensitive areas a
little more than necessary especially
given that he wasn't wearing bulky
clothing or anything like that
Williamson says the whole thing started
when agents found a laptop in his book
bag as it went through the scanning
machine they then said her son would
have to submit to a pat-down even though
he did not set off the body scanner she
requested they screen him in other ways
because her son suffers from sensory
processing disorder which makes him
sensitive to touch in the facebook video
the agent explains the procedure and
then packs down his back side front and
down his legs his supervisor who was
observing them then instructs the man to
complete the final step as per policy
the TSA officer uses the back of his
hand for pat downs over sensitive areas
of the body the TSA says the boy
cooperated during the screening process
and all approved procedures were
followed as for the wait time in a
statement the agency says the passengers
were at the checkpoint for approximately
45 minutes which included the time it
took to discuss screening procedures
with the mother and to screen three
carry-on items that required further
inspection his
first question to me was I don't
understand why they did this I don't
know what I did wrong and to me that was
a sign of trauma for him to think that
he had done anything wrong the new
procedures were put in place after a
2015 audit found that there were serious
security lapses Williamson has filed a
complaint with the TSA but has not heard
back charlie Omar thanks